Diese Erfindung könnte den Durchbruch bedeuten:
Laut einem internationalen Forschungsteam
könnte ein neu entwickeltes Material Reisen
zu anderen Sternen möglich machen!
Zum Beispiel zum Stern Proxima Centauri: Eine
Sonde würde für die Entfernung von 4,2 Lichtjahren
dann nur rund 20 Jahre brauchen.
Möglich machen soll das ein sogenanntes Aerogel
- ein Material, das extreme Temperatursprünge
ganz easy aushält und somit als Laser-Segel
dienen könnte.
Ob und wie dann demnächst tatsächlich eine
Reise zu Proxima Centauri möglich ist.
Clixoom Science & Fiction. hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, Abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann und nur verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen Die Eigenschaften der
sogenannten “Aerogele” sind außergewöhnlich:
Die Stoffe sind ultraleicht und sehr porös.
Kein Wunder, denn das Material besteht aus
sehr dünnen Metall- oder Keramik-Schichten
und häufig zu mehr als 99 Prozent aus Luft
bzw. freiem Raum.
Quasi ein Hauch von Nichts.
Und schon jetzt werden die Stoffe in der Praxis
eingesetzt: Siliziumoxid-Aerogele beispielsweise
in Raumanzügen.
Aerogele dienen zudem als Dämmstoffe.
Doch bislang sind das alles Spezialanwendungen,
da sich die Herstellung derzeit noch als sehr
kompliziert und aufwendig gestaltet.
Zudem hatten die Aerogele bis jetzt eine große
Schwachstelle: Bei großen Temperaturschwankungen
zerbricht das Material nämlich sehr leicht.
Doch genau diesem Problem hat sich ein nun
internationales Forschungsteam angenommen
- und das äußerst erfolgreich.
Die neu entwickelten Aerogele bestehen zu
mehr als 99 Prozent aus Luft und halten sogar
sehr schnellen Temperaturwechseln von mehr
als 1000 Grad Celsius stand - und das eröffnet
uns bislang ungeahnte Möglichkeiten!
Aber von vorne: Die Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen
konstruierten zunächst ein symmetrisches
Gerüst aus Graphen.
Wir haben hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
schon öfter über diesen “Wunderstoff”
berichtet!
Bei diesen atomar dünnen Kohlenstoffschichten
handelt es sich um das dünnste Material der
Welt - und dabei ist es härter als Diamant.
Das Forschungsteam baute somit zweidimensionale
Schichten, auf denen es unter einer Schutzatmosphäre
aus Argon kristalline Lagen aus Bornitrid
wachsen ließ.
Das Graphen wurde dann bei etwa 600 Grad Celsius
abgetrennt, sodass nur noch das Aerogel aus
den Bornitrid-Schichten in einer äußerst
symmetrischen Anordnung übrig blieb.
Dieses Netzwerk sieht von der Seite aus betrachtet
aus wie eine Art Spinnennetz.
Und die Metastruktur begründet die besonderen
Eigenschaften des neu entwickelten Aerogels:
Statt sich bei Erwärmung auszudehnen, zieht
es sich zusammen.
Wenn das Material mechanisch gestreckt wird,
wird es in der Mitte nicht dünner, sondern
dicker.
In der Fachsprache spricht man dann von einer
negativen Poissonszahl und einem negativen
Wärmeausdehnungskoeffizienten.
Dazu Xiangfeng Duan, einer der beteiligten
Forscher: “Unser Aerogel zeigt sowohl eine
herausragende mechanische als auch thermische
Stabilität für Superisolatoren unter extremen
Bedingungen”.
Das Forschungsteam testete das Aerogel aufs
Äußerste: Sie erhitzten es auf bis zu 1500
Grad Celsius - und das in sehr kurzer Zeit.
Schnell kühlten sie es dann wieder ab - und
zwar auf bis zu minus 198 Grad Celsius.
Extreme Temperaturschwankungen also - und
dennoch blieb die Aerogel-Struktur erhalten.
Anders als gewöhnliche Keramiken, die dabei
zerbröseln.
Doch es gibt noch weitere bemerkenswerte Eigenschaften
des Aerogels: Es verfügt nämlich über eine
extrem geringe Dichte.
Stellt Euch das mal vor: Eine Probe des Aerogels
in der Größe eines Würfels wiegt gerade
mal ein Tausendstel Gramm!
Zudem dehnt sich das Material ohne Druck wieder
in seine ursprüngliche Form zurück - selbst,
wenn es mit einer Presse auf einen Bruchteils
seiner Größe zusammengedrückt wird.
Drei Faktoren sorgen wohl dafür, dass das
Material so gut isoliert: Zum einen behindern
winzig kleine Brüche in der Bornitrid-Struktur
die Wärmeleitung.
Zudem handelt es sich bei den Porenwänden
um Doppelwände, die an eine Doppelverglasung
bei Fenstern erinnern, und somit gut isolieren.
Als weiterer Punkt ist die Wärmeleitung im
Feststoff reduziert - und zwar durch die sehr
geringe Dichte des Materials.
Zusammengefasst vereint das Material somit
also einige sehr besondere Eigenschaften!
Und die lassen das Forschungsteam krasse Visionen
entwickeln.
Aerogele könnten demnach für eine Revolution
in der Erkundung des Weltraumes sorgen.
Da das Material so gut isoliert, könnte es
als Hitzeschutzkacheln von Raum-Transportern
eingesetzt werden.
Denn die Luftreibung beim Wiedereintritt in
die Erdatmosphäre sorgt für extreme Temperaturen.
Und auch bei einer Drehung im erdnahen Orbit
muss eine Sonde einen Temperaturwechsel von
mehreren hundert Grad überstehen können.
Laut dem Forschungsteam könnte das Aerogel
als Material für ein Lasersegel dienen.
Laserstrahlen könnten dann das sehr leichte
Material auf rund 20 Prozent der Lichtgeschwindigkeit
bringen 20 Jahre würde die Reise zum 4,2
Lichtjahren entfernten Stern Proxima Centauri
den Berechnungen zufolge dauern…Doch nicht
nur das: Das neu entwickelte Aerogel könnte
auch im Automobilbau eingesetzt werden.
Seine starken Isolationseigenschaften könnten
beispielsweise Auto-Bauteile vor den hohen
Temperaturen schützen, die etwa von Katalysatoren
ausgehen.
Und auch in Wasserstoffautos könnte sich
das Material als nützlich erweisen, denn
es könnte die Reaktion in der Brennstoffzelle
genauso gut beschleunigen wie das derzeit
eingesetzte kostspielige Platin!
Eine große Herausforderung in Brennstoffzellenfahrzeugen,
die damit endlich gelöst wäre.
Ein Problem dabei ist bislang noch der komplizierte
Herstellungsprozess.
Um das Aerogel auf Masse zu produzieren, müsste
noch ein geeignetes Verfahren entwickelt werden.
Doch das Forschungsteam ist optimistisch.
Dazu Duan: “Derzeit arbeiten wir außerdem
an extrem leichten Aerogelen, die sogar noch
robuster, flexibler und hitzebeständiger
werden könnten”.
Wow.
Das iorre ist ja dann wirklich, was aus diesem
wirklich extremen Material hergestellt werden
kann.
Es kann so viel revolutionieren, wie es zum
Beispiel die Supraleitung gemacht hat und
noch macht.
Plötzlich sind Dinge denkbar, wie wir bisher
für unmöglich gehalten haben.
Nanotechnologien – Wie wir die Grundbausteine
unserer Welt verändern können unbedingt
draufklicken da gibt Cedric vom Kanal Doktor
Whatson einen noch umfassenderen Überblick
über das Thema, also draufklicken, ansehen
und abonnieren.